hello everyone my name is ian
welcome to the 35th ever iced coffee
hour
podcast
uh we're making a lot of money on this
podcast
nine three eight seventy three that's a
lot of digits baby
i'll take it that's good enough yeah
thanks so much for coming on now no it's
good no no it's good
all right thanks so much for coming on
we really appreciate this you just
filmed up
like an hour long shoot with graham for
the main channel and you still have the
energy to do this
i'm a machine you were made for this yes
god crafted me in his lab and put a lot
of
testosterone in me and a lot of dopamine
stamina i would say just to keep filming
yeah just to keep going so thank you so
much for coming on
i'm always curious about this i actually
don't know the answer to this why did
you
come up with the name idubbbz tv
i'm wondering if i should give up game
on myself or not
this would be like
this would be new news for the internet
i think everyone
knows it's okay very few people watch
this podcast relative to the other
things
first name ian last name
last name donovan last name
wait carter oh that's a lie that's an
internet lie
no yes i don't usually give that away
but it's an internet lie
last name starts with a w german
n well i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give
the full last name you guys have to do
some creepy kind of research to figure
it out
but it starts with a w i dubs
[Music]
so we have to figure out your last name
no you know you don't have to figure it
out
i'll tell you guys after the i stopped
yeah
that's amazing why keep the lie going
though what's what's the big deal well i
mean it's
it's not gonna matter now because
everyone like this is why i avoid doing
it because everyone in your
in your stupid comment section bless
their little hearts
they're going to plaster it all over the
place now and it's going to be upvoted
like crazy because we brought attention
to it
but that's okay i'm vulnerability risk
that
yeah yeah but why carry it so far why
not just be upfront with your last name
then no one would care about it they
don't care because it's so secretive now
that's true which is exactly why i'm
giving it up
on the iced coffee hour 33 thousand
dollars
good wow is there a reason you put three
bees right was it three b
yeah one b and two b were taken
that makes sense yeah right yeah i'm
committed i'm like i need this name but
i don't want to put like numbers in it
who would take them who who took those
accounts probably
people with identical names or i don't
know the the
the letter and dubs is a very popular
format okay
like among hip-hop moguls
j-dubs yeah t-dubs but what about the tv
part at the end was idubbbz
take it already so you got like three
bees no no let's put tv
exactly tv one so it uh
first channel was demonetized because i
was watching my own ads
not actually right not actually uh but
they
they they were a little suss on the
channel so they
suspended the account so i needed to
make a new one
and uh obviously three b's and a z was
taken so i did add the tv oh you had
idubbbz yeah
i have both channels yeah wow yeah
sell that first channel i bet there's
someone out there who would buy it from
you even if it's democracy oh definitely
yeah yeah that might be a good uh good
video i sold my
old first name
and you can go through and take a tour
because there's a bunch of unlisted
videos that's a lot of content
is everything unlisted uh no not
everything
how have i not seen that yeah was this
just minecraft content
there's a lot of minecraft content me
and my buddy rad jor were playing this
minecraft daisy combo game called mind z
whereas like zombies and minecraft okay
i've played that
yeah how old are you 22
22. oh man jackson young yeah there's
some stuff on there i was trying to
break into it the other day but i don't
have the login credentials i'll need to
like
figure out how to contact google to hook
me up
do you have a contact at google no
nobody does
nobody does gosh except that's the yeah
the
like i don't know very business forward
people i think ethan
uh has a contact or a couple contacts
because he's like
very on the money when it comes to that
stuff but i'm just like i need help from
one
google person at a time every three
years
so i'll reach out and i i won't know
their email or
they'll be defunct three years later so
we have a genuine question this is quite
a bit
embarrassing actually but why did you
agree to come on
is that an embarrassing question i don't
know because you know how to ask that
yeah a lot of the times when we do
collaborations with people like
pokemane oh yeah i question we just were
like why does she want to make a video
with
us if eric graham if anything it's like
it's like it doesn't
okay so i don't get to talk about my
financials or any of the
i guess sort of like even meta youtube
stuff
very often so like having an excuse to
do it it would be
wildly inappropriate for me to do it on
my channel me to be like
hey guys forget the commentary forget
the
this or that i'm going to talk to you
about
what's in my bank account today like
your audience would
love it they might i bet they would uh
but i i know that coming
onto your turf your audience is
definitely going to
be approving of it you know that's the
theory i think
that graham's youtube channel is
disproportionately popular amongst
youtubers like more youtubers seems like
like your channel because like pokeyman
it's like what does what does she have
any association with graham you know
but we had it on yeah yeah i think you
have a few things going for you i think
the uh you like responded to like
i think pokemane like watching an
original video of you yeah on something
else
and i think you coming at it how you did
where it's like i'm just gonna go
through like the general critiques or
the general things that
you know because these are common
questions that a lot of people have i
think especially when they're viewing
these weird jubilee-esque videos
and you're just getting kind of sound
bites uh so i think that clarification
i don't know it made me confident that
uh
this would be an enjoyable experience i
hope it is
now the pressure's on because yeah like
jack said i'm always questioning like
because i don't feel worthy a lot of the
time like for pokemon like
she could just she could just she has so
many people but she could just post it
on her channel
yeah and uh i'm like but and i'm sure
that i don't know if there are bigger
channels on if that's the thing i don't
know if there are bigger channels about
business
on youtube right now maybe valuetainment
i think
but they're like they're like a
corporation and you have to collab with
them you're just a youtuber
right i don't know well thank you so
much yes thanks a lot we appreciate it
we're consistently being surprised i
know
do you have any tattoos uh no
however i do have this uh yeah right
there you see that
oh yeah pencil oh i've got a couple of
those
yeah yeah my dad spooked me when i was
coming out of the garage and i
somehow stabbed myself with a pencil you
know it's funny i actually have one
little thing you can't really see
anymore but right there
on my thumb a little mark from lead that
when i was a kid just a pencil went
into my thumb and it's still like a
little just you see a little bit of lead
right there
it's never gone away so we're so what
you're saying is we're tough guys
yeah yeah i got one too
significant it's the same sort of yeah
blood brothers wow
so would you get any tattoos or you you
know oh yeah definitely
it's just there's so many other things
that like are taking up my
interest i i actually imagine it being
more of a later in life thing
really yeah yeah i feel like it's a
young person's thing to get a tattoo
yeah i think maybe if you're doing it
for like identity purposes or you like
i don't know like you just like the look
of them like you can
get them kind of whenever uh would you
want to do one that's meaningful
no absolutely not an east and i talk
about it all the time there's a ton of
people
criticizing like anise's tattoos saying
like oh
it's so basic and then they'll like send
a picture of like their tattoo that has
meaning
and it's like a triforce with their
mom's face and there's something
symbol right here yeah it's like all
right meaning
because your mom gave you zelda when you
were three awesome dude
so yeah the meaning thing i think is
silly if you want to have meaning that's
great for you but i think
most people do it because they like the
aesthetics and the look of it
i think it looks cool yeah yeah i
couldn't do it
i thought that you never graham says he
wants an entire sleeve but only if you
would have it for like a year yeah if it
could disappear in like two years
i would do it a slightly just have it
because i think it's cool looking
because i've always been in like the
whole like
music like stuff and i've just it was
cool to be like playing the drums
like a sleeve does that surprise you
about graham um
not surprisingly here i feel like the
everyone i think a lot of people will
see the tattooed look
and like anything like a piece of
clothing and they'll be like that looks
cool
you know you make some assumptions of
like oh a little bit mysterious maybe
they got a bit of a background i think
it builds some amount of like visual
character
that you don't already have um so it
makes sense uh
especially the only having for a year
yeah
i just want i don't want anything
permanent like that like i
i just i would get tired of it or i'd
look back at it or
i don't know i just i couldn't do it i
think it would be funny and it would be
unique
for like to have a youtube channel
talking about investing and roth iras
and stuff like that rental properties
just be like
tatted up yeah i and you have the
chops now that you could do that right
it's not going to affect your growth
going forward
i don't know because there are
definitely i think certain people in the
business world that are still
very much uh losers
losers they they just they won't be able
to see past that and there are people at
so i almost see that it's like why be a
little bit divisive
if you get help
what if you're able to like educate
these losers about it and it the whole
thing
is like like a crowdfund or you sell
space to brands
yeah um what brands you got like yeah
yeah
on there yeah they buy it they buy space
on your arm
you can even sell space to fans that
reminds me that pixel website
where is it the million pixels whatever
million dollar website
million dollar homepage is what it was
called do you hear about this no what is
it genius idea the kid wanted to pay for
his college so he creates his website
and he sells ad space permanently on
this website
and it was like a dollar a pixel and he
had a million pixels so he wanted to
sell out
uh the entire front page his home page
he did how did he get traffic
it went viral yeah this is like back in
like the early 2000s or like the late
1990s
should be i think it's yet called the
million dollar home page wow i gotta
check that out yeah and it's still up
dope a screenshot guys so you can see it
what else jack yeah i do want to say i
really appreciate uh the new content
you're putting on
i love it i loved your old content too
i'm actually i'm a huge fan i was really
nervous to meet you
and uh i love the transition and i i
just want to say something about the uh
the dax flame thing
uh-huh and also actually really quickly
i do want to say one other quick note
um when are you gonna do something with
the report of the week
oh i love that yeah that's going to
happen it better have hopes
he never has gone on anyone else's
channel right uh he's done something
with like business insider i think but
that's
yeah but that was just like an article
right or like a quick video yeah quick
video
uh i don't know i've uh i think briefly
reached out to him
uh he seems i don't know he's a funny
guy on like twitter and stuff but
i don't know how into the idea he is but
uh
that could eventually come for sure i
think he's just nervous to appear on
other people's channels and he's also
a i think a very large introvert yeah
definitely
yeah but that would blow up because
people like me are just like wildly
curious what is that like
you know what i mean right and like he's
like wearing air jordans and basketball
shorts down to his ankles
sweatpants yeah oversized t-shirt
yeah like supreme it's like i don't know
i i just think it'll be interesting
head to toe driving around a lambo yeah
you would think though if he did that
someone would spot him like he would
have a picture out there
of just you got caught yeah it's true
yeah there are plenty of people creeping
around in public who could catch that
i think he's i don't know if it's his
grandparents house or what it is but i
think that's where he spends most of his
time now he's not
yeah uh driving around getting fast food
that would be amazing
yeah so if you ever want to do that you
got definitely a full-time watcher
okay okay yeah you got at least that
mind you have at least two views
people will love it they will love it
yeah i yeah
really quick we have a word from our
sponsor grammarly there have been so
many times in my life where i've had
trouble writing effectively or
expressing myself clearly
for example usually when we invite our
guests onto the podcast it requires me
to reach out to the guest via dm
asking if they'd like to come on this
process can be really timely and my
writing needs to be exact in order to be
successful i don't want my dm to come
off weird in cases like this
it really helps to have grammarly
premium grammarly is a digital writing
assistant that will review
any writing that you do and tell you how
your tone comes off give you alternative
vocab suggestions and help out with your
structure i know not everyone has to dm
people trying to get them on their
podcast but grammarly premium can be
used in plenty of situations such as
checking in on your family
sending recaps to teams in your
organization or sharing big news with
your friends
i find myself using grammarly premium
more and more just because of how easy
it is
plus it's nice to know that whenever i
am sending a message to someone i know
that like i'm not messing up on the
structure
my grammar and it's not going to come
off odd on top of all this grammarly
just makes me a better writer which i
believe is a really important skill to
have evaluate your writing with 20 off
grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com
iced coffee that's 20 off grammarly
premium at grammarly g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash iced coffee and with that
said thank you so much and back to the
podcast
definitely get that sense a lot of
people have been saying report of the
week have they
yeah because it's just like i think it
comes naturally to a lot of people who
watch these videos they're like oh i've
seen the fatty thing i've seen the dax
thing like
these are some characters that are a bit
awkward i want to know more about them
uh so it's like who else is like that so
report of the week comes up often
do you just want to do these these like
awkward
figures who really just have a unique
story or do you want to just
whoever comes up comes up yeah
whatever's whatever's the most
interesting i think we have some people
right now on the docket
who are uh interesting characters uh
can't see more than that
but they uh they'll scratch an itch a
curiosity itch
oh that's good how do you find people is
are these people that
you just oh yeah you watch i mean it's
the same
way people come across report of the
week right like it's just
you know browsing hours and hours of
youtube videos you know
going down rabbit holes um
so yeah i mean it's it's constantly
shifting we have a big document of like
people were like
crossing off lists and saying oh that
won't work or this
is looking likely or you know all sorts
of things have people ever not agreed
to do a documentary like you've come to
them and say listen i prefer you not do
it
yeah definitely there was uh there was
someone that we were
looking to do it with and they just kind
of got cold feet
and i understood why i think they were
afraid that we were going to put them in
a bad light because they
saw the fatty documentary and they were
like
you guys are just treating him like a
clown like it's just a spectacle like
you you want to make me a spectacle that
sort of thing
and i understand the sentiment it
becomes a little bit different when you
get to know them
and that's why i was you know i'm okay
with doing it because
it's all in good fun we wouldn't do
anything that people weren't like
comfortable with you know
would you ever consider doing one of
those videos on someone you made a
content cop
about yeah it's like a redemption thing
doing it on leafy would be the most
amazing thing in the entire world yeah i
mean
break the internet yeah i'll put it out
there i'm i'm pretty much
willing to do it with with anyone um
that you had on content copy yeah so
if if someone wants to reach out but
it's one of those things i don't blame
anyone
who like that's why i wouldn't want to
reach out because it's kind of like
hey i made like a decent amount of money
and views and attention off of you
i wouldn't want want to then like
intrusively double dip and say you have
every right to hate me
but hey you wanna make even more out of
you yeah
[Applause]
yeah it seems like a bit much but i'd be
okay with it i feel like they could
appreciate it because it's you wanting
to know more about them and
understand them well yeah and there's a
history there that we could explore i
think that could be really cool
um because i've definitely grown i've
changed my mind on a lot of things so i
think there would be
a lot to unpack and a lot to explore but
it's up to them it's not
yeah for the content cops um obviously i
i think none of that was personal but
where am i getting with this was was a
lot of that just in good fun
in good spirits or do you think people
were were genuinely hurt
by some of these things or do you think
it's just like just internet drama going
back and forth
oh i mean like all the above i would say
like a mixture of all that
like it's you know sometimes it's like
you know a lot of these channels i just
genuinely didn't like
the the either the videos they were
making or the way they were like kind of
putting themselves out there
i sort of tried to stick to i don't know
like
more objective things right but at the
end of the day it's just like
a lot of it i'm not happy with just
because
i i don't think there's any way i could
i could have
done that without doing something more
like a documentary that's a little bit
more fair
um because people
will kind of take what they want out of
it like it's all
in an air of negativity mostly and so
even though i'm being negative about a
certain list of things people be like
oh like we're hating this person now
let's hate on this person now
and they'll add more things to that list
and it's like i'm not adding all those
things to the list i was like pretty
specific
so this is getting a little more deep
here um
what do you think of graham let me know
what you think what do you think of
cancel culture
yes or no yes yes
so you like it i just thought it was a
funny question inside you wanted it
i have a it's it's it's seguing and oh
interesting
maybe maybe do you think that your
content cops were any different than
canceling
no so you think they were canceling yeah
wow that just shattered my brain yeah
okay yeah i mean i don't take it like it
is what it is like
it i think you have to be a little bit
logically consistent with it like if you
don't think it's a big deal that you
know so and so
did this list of bad things like i don't
know
there there's a spectrum right like i
think about all the people i may i've
made videos on and like
like pretty far on that spectrum of like
objective things that are
like worth criticizing i think you have
someone like keemstar where it's like
yeah this is like a net negative on the
world
yeah so it's like how do you like
counteract that a little bit and it's
like
yeah a little bit of criticism a little
bit of um bringing people's attention to
it
but um there are other people like i
think the leafy content cop where it's
like
yeah this guy makes commentary videos
and he kind of like makes fun of people
i'm literally going to do the same thing
to him and it's like
that is not a net it wasn't necessarily
the same as it was for some of the other
people you did on content cops right
yeah yeah but the idea in mind with
those episodes was to deep
platform people no no definitely not
um like with something like the keemstar
one like i i wouldn't look for him to be
de-platformed no way
i think i guess that's the distinction
you're making
between cancer culture it's very hard
because i i
often think that a lot of people who you
know get canceled
end up just they do it themselves kind
of way
not not by their actions beforehand but
their actions after
people say that cancel so and so right
like because you can keep making videos
um if people happen to stop watching it
you know you could chalk it up to just
about anything right like maybe you're
maybe you're on your way down anyway
right
like maybe your views were going down
anyway and it was just a kind of a
matter of time
um but there's a lot of people i mean i
i think uh maybe christie
ellia is an example right yeah comedian
yeah
yeah um he like i think i mean i haven't
seen any of his stuff yeah he's just
disappeared he just disappeared
and it sort of depends on the thing like
if you
uh some of it's like really shameful and
feels really bad did you show your face
in public again
and i think that kind of stuff is like
it's like
i think it's really bad to make people
feel like that level of shame
because that is unmatched right like
there's no
like average person who has to deal with
that like sort of online like
mob so it's like we're really unprepared
for it like i i can't even like
i don't really even understand how like
a therapist would deal with someone
who's going through that because it's
like
where is your comparison that you're
getting like like
inundated in social media maybe
inundated in your day-to-day life like i
don't know how you handle it so i think
that aspect is really
tough it reminds me yeah that reminds me
of a story
uh i think three years ago three and a
half years ago when i first started
making youtube videos i had this guy
reach out for a consulting call
and i took this is the hardest call i
ever had to do i don't think i've ever
told anybody about this actually
i'm not i don't know if i should just
mention it
just don't say their name if you don't
you can say their name and i'll bleep it
out
the context gives it away yeah the
context will give it away we could use
your best judgment here but
it was actually i'll get rid of some of
the details
it was someone who is like you type in
their name
and instantaneously the first thing
comes up is some like really horrible
cases that came up
uh and some really serious allegations
against them
and because he has a really unique name
and he said he had to drop out of school
he left his job uh no one will hire him
he spent all of his money defending him
his parents spent all of their money
defending him they have no money left he
can't get a job anymore
and wanted to come to me for advice and
my advice was you have to change your
name
now the crazy thing was that he was
proven not guilty
but that was a year later and by that
time all the articles that got bumped up
to the top were like allegation
you know this this this and that it's a
big case but a year later
no one covered that he was guilty so
he's like even though i'm guilty
people don't believe it even though he's
not guilty and he's not guilty
yeah i think that is like the that is
the penultimate
like example of how bad it can be like
that is
that's it and that could be the case for
a lot of uh you know
youtubers yeah streamers yeah but it
goes to show you like some of that stuff
will stick with you for a very long time
and i think we as humans are not dealt
for that like you have to think
we're used to being in like a small
tribe let's say like a little community
and not used to going out in public and
like everyone universally just typing in
your name and google and be like oh
you did that mm-hmm i don't want to risk
you just being awesome yes
oh absolutely i do agree i think that a
lot of the people that have been maybe
canceled
their actions that led to being canceled
they didn't really foresee like maybe
how bad they were maybe
sometimes they were just being like
ignorant and not malicious
you know yeah and then of course they
lost their entire platform they can't
show their face anymore
right and um of course you can't really
use ignorance as an excuse
yeah but i think you but it's different
yeah i think people
want equity and they think like you have
with a lot of famous people i think they
perceive their joy and
you know the life they've experienced to
be like very high up there
in level of happiness and enjoyment so
they're like i want that same level
in the other way where you're getting
torn down
and they don't really realize like like
this like
way worse happens all the time all
around them
at their dentist's office you know like
wherever
and like oftentimes
no one knows about it like so it's
that i think it's just important to
understand that it's like it's a
different world
and it doesn't necessarily need to be
like you don't need to tear people down
as much like
their mistakes being in the public eye
is good enough like that's good enough
you don't need to like further push it
the hard part now too is that everything
is recorded
like every tweet you've made every
facebook post and like
i think i got on myspace i was like 14
or 15 years old on my
i'm sure i said some stupid stuff as
like a 15 year old on myspace
thankfully that website's like you can't
even log in anymore so that's all erased
but uh i know it's like you you've just
done things that
30 40 years ago that never would have
been like you don't have a text message
right
right but you just change as a person
and you evolve and you look back and
that's cringey shouldn't have done that
but that's a lot of the stuff that
people
are getting canceled for sort of the i
don't know what you'd call it the
24-hour cancelings of people where it's
like
you know someone's name is trending
dojicat is trending and it's like
it's trending because she tweeted some
silly
like you know five years ago and it's
like that's
what everyone is doing right now like
you need to do that
to get attention like when i didn't have
any followers i was
saying the worst imaginable on twitter
just to try to get attention and like
yeah i'm not gonna delete it by the time
you know that i do get that attention
so it's like i think everyone's doing
some version of that because it's like
i'm not being heard by the world
i i if you're being heard by the world
since you were born you're not going to
say the crazy stuff
it might be like a curve like right now
we're climbing and uh
soon enough we're going to realize that
all these people that are now 35
30 yeah they did stupid stuff everyone
does stupid stuff when you're 16 you
know 15 17.
and then all of a sudden we're gonna
realize everyone did it and we're gonna
come back down
and we're gonna take it for what it is
instead of maybe hyping things up yeah
how about
everything before 20. we just chopped
that up i would love that
i would actually 20 it's just like you
just forgive it yeah
it's good it's a little bit that way in
other facets of life for sure
you know but it's tough though because i
think about how i was playing minecraft
at you know 23
and you know gaming it up with my boys
putting it on youtube
it's like everyone matures at a
different rate
and like i think like you know other
people's 16
was closer to my 20 or something you
know like not it's
sadly are you more careful about what
you say today and like what you put out
there
or are you still more free and just
whatever you feel you
wanted to say uh i mean i've always been
careful about it
like i think the sort of the more edgy
content that i did back in the day
i shouldn't say back in the day a few
years ago um
like that was all intentional it wasn't
like
i was i was just saying speaking my mind
like a lot of that stuff you need to be
intentional if you're gonna say it and
my
i think my thought process was if i
start this off like as bad as it gets
then the rest of it will be smooth
sailing it's sort of
like a strategic move i look at a lot of
comedians and a lot of comedians who
just sort of
have some of the worst jokes they can
kind of just get away with a lot more
yeah that's good answer
great answer let's get back to the money
all right let's talk money
all right all right you guys have
vehicles yes
do you want to speak a little closer
though you guys have vehicles yes yes
sir
you guys have teslas yes no jack wants a
tesla so badly
i tell jack not to get a tesla because
he i i think it's so important to always
have that little carrot
dangling in front of your face that like
you could work towards that yeah
i know as soon as jack gets that tesla
it's the next thing
it's not even it's the next thing you're
gonna you're you just relax
afterwards you're like oh come on i'm
not gonna relax in my work graham you
get a test
when the tesla's the one thing that you
want more than anything as soon as you
achieve that
yeah but i think that that's speaking
for some people i'm a simple person
there isn't a lot that i want i think
you're similar like i don't think that
because you said money doesn't drive you
i don't think it drives me either
there's just a cert like i want
something and once i get i'll be
satisfied
i think graham has a point in that
you the pre-gaming is
actually some of the funnest part right
where it's like
the anticipation of getting it thinking
about getting it you know
if you're buying a tesla stretch that
purchase over like a few months
you know keep visiting the website yeah
this is it all the time
okay i see that it's 560 something
dollars every day right i checked
you know prices have changed i i think
um
uh just use the philosophy of like maybe
get it when you can buy like three of
them
well i told jack when he gets a rental
property that could pay for the tesla
then he could get the tesla that that's
that's what i think it would be a fair
trade-off
everyone has like their own little like
method of the madness i think that's the
vacation
that makes a lot of sense what do you
drive uh
i'm really happy with my car it's a uh
2019 subaru outback
nice cool yes uh it's a recent purchase
i got
rid of my jeep i was rolling around with
the jeep for a long time
and uh it's awesome i go off-roading
it has good mpgs did you buy new uh
no i bought it used um off of the
carvana website okay
uh really i'll tell you what
uh used car dealerships car dealerships
in general are absolute hell
and that's like a good example what we
were talking about in the interview like
you know
put money in things that like like good
experiences or good businesses that
you've
uh you know seen and that was one of
them where i was like holy
they dropped the car off i didn't have
to deal with some
lunatic and it was way cheaper
than you know any any other car
dealership that i went to
um yeah it was like it's a man it only
had like 9 000 miles on it
and i paid like 23 000
and it's a like a nine thousand dollar
car yeah
so it's pretty substantial cash about uh
yeah okay yeah what's your opinion on
that cars
in the beginning i'd always say get a
loan on it but i think now for me at
this point it's not worth getting a loan
right
it'll change though depending on maybe
how expensive the car is
i think it's really just the perspective
of it and uh
i wouldn't exert myself anymore to try
to save like an extra 50 a month by
writing off a car loan and try it it's
just not worth
the hassle i think at this point it's
just getting alone unless they really
have to
that makes sense yeah what are you what
are you riding uh 2006
lexus rx330 it's my grandma's car that's
sick
yeah what kind of a nice guy it's white
and the uh the steering wheel and the
shifter they're both like
wood glossy wood that's cool yeah i want
to see that well
i guess you wouldn't see that in a tesla
but no you can get the steering wheel
yeah wood yeah i like jack's car a lot
we took it to vegas one time and the
seats are so comfortable nice ride
yeah it feels like you're on one of
those leather couches you know those 90s
leather couches that you just sink into
a little
right right it feels like that that's
cool it's really nice
only 70 000 miles too oh okay you can
keep chugging on that oh yeah
okay that's neat yeah so what's your
dream car
really quick you guys we have a word
from our sponsor simply safe everyone
wants to keep their home and family safe
whether it's from a break-in a fire
flooding or a medical emergency simply
save home security delivers
award-winning 24 7 protection with
simplisafe you don't just get an arsenal
of cameras and sensors
you get the best professional monitors
in the business
they've got your back day and night
ready to send police fire or emts when
you need the most straight to your door
but that is not even the best part about
simply safe their systems can be set up
in less than 30 minutes which is nuts
because usually for home security
systems
you need to hire someone or it would
take you hours plus with simplisafe
there's no long-term contract
no hidden fees and no installation costs
right now my listeners get a free home
security camera when you purchase a
simply safe system
at simplisafe.com iced coffee you also
get a 60-day risk free trial
there is nothing to lose visit
simplysafe.com iced coffee
for your free security camera today
that's simplysafe.com
iced coffee as always more information
is down below thank you so much and back
to the podcast you can get any comments
oh definitely the tesla really
why don't you get one um i think it's
it's just
kind of what graham was saying it's like
this thing to look forward to in the
future
like i don't i don't drive too often
um it would be super useful in the type
of trips that i make you know up to la
and everything
but i don't know this may look i don't
want this to come off the wrong way
okay this is not anything directed
towards you but this is i want your
advice on
yours as well since i am 22
i feel like there is something different
about having a tesla at 22
than there is at 27. like right now i'm
still
so youthful you know like i'm so
youthful
that is the wrong way it is such an
awesome thing to say i'm
brimming with youth no no but like okay
you're still youthful it's like
like there's i don't know i feel like i
still haven't gone through like that
crazy
maturation phase yet yeah yeah yeah you
know maybe like
say maybe not you think but immature
yeah
he's calling us old no no there's no
point to this i i
really did not oh no no no no no i'm not
taking it of course
of course yeah well but yeah i guess
what do you what do you mean when you
say that
what if i were to wait you know four
more years and technically i'm able to
afford it now
but what if i waited till i'm 26 and i
feel like
you know dangling the carrots good but
having your dream car
at 22 versus having it at 26 while i'm
still so
i i i don't know it's like the
difference between getting a lambo at 20
versus a lambo at 30.
the lambo at 20 is a much different
experience than lambo
30. all right enough of that enough on
the test
let's change this i just think it's
important to always have the thing to
look forward to
yeah oh i wanted uh uh i've i've noticed
i haven't seen the videos but i've
noticed you've been
posting some videos about bitcoin
because or crypto in general because
that's popping
yeah yeah what uh what give me the
skinny on what you've been saying in
these videos
okay i put one percent of my portfolio
into bitcoin and ethereum
um so 60 bitcoin 40 ethereum
ethereum's actually done better for me
as an investment overall
than bitcoin so far um what changed my
mind i've always been against
cryptocurrency i've always just felt
like i've dabbled in it just to see what
it's like
just wanted to get some experience it's
not the appeal but i was like yeah
um what really got me was a lot of the
mainstream adoption and
how so many people were putting a small
portion of their money into bitcoin
and i'm thinking with the amount of
money
just entering the economy right now
there is no chance
that we don't see inflation in the
future i just think there's so much
money just pouring out there and i think
to risk
one percent of my portfolio that would
be
a better use of my money than keeping
that one percent in cash let's just say
and i think there's a bigger risk to not
investing one percent than there is
to invest one percent even if that one
percent drops ninety percent like so
what i lose one percent not a big deal
uh but in a small chance that maybe it
just does really well long term yeah i
just i don't want to look back and be
like
i wish i kept it yeah that's like my
same logic with it
i was slightly i mean is that a recent
change then
uh this month yeah when did i buy i
bought in i think
beginning of the year like three weeks
ago yeah beginning of the year
and honestly part of that reason was
like i had so much cash
and i'm like it's stupid just keeping i
may as well just
one percent into this and just if i need
the money like i'll just sell it
but it's it's certainly interesting and
the more i look into it believe it or
not the more
um open i am i am to it like like
two years ago three years ago i was like
what's the point
um but honestly the more research i'm
doing i wouldn't tell people to be like
go all in or invent like this is a great
investment but i just think long term it
could be a good hold
yeah what i've been seeing is a lot of
people
like pretty level-headed people doing
that sort of technique
not one percent necessarily closer to
like 10
um as a sort of a gold replacement if
you if you are a gold investor
yeah not investor but like a hedge
against inflation kind of thing
um that's what i've done um you're ten
percent
yeah ten percent in gold or bitcoin
bitcoin not
the bitcoin ethereum kind of the same
way why did you start buying crypto
um or earlier than january it was
some i think in may
and then some yeah that was a good time
wow may so that would have been it would
have been about
seven five seven thousand yeah and then
uh
year before that i got in at like three
or four thousand
oh my god it's it's a good
like i'm i'm becoming more convinced
because at the time
it wasn't too much money for me um
but i like that the idea of like can you
stand to lose this money
and if you're kind of okay with losing
that money it's totally worth
putting in there did you go in with ten
percent of your net worth or did it
grow to ten percent um
uh
because i'm sure that it's grown faster
yeah it really has but i mean
everything's kind of been growing in
tandem
i would say um yeah it's
more so close closer to grown to ten
percent okay um
and i'm just like i'm totally fine with
that i'm
putting more in but it's uh
it's a bit of a wild ride yeah but you
also don't hold index funds
no which i feel like if you for every
dollar you have in bitcoin you should at
least have like
one to two in index funds at least index
funds are like
the foundation they're just a safety net
right you're never going to see them go
down
20 i mean i guess it's possible but
right rare you're going to see a big
drop like that versus
let's say something like a capital
preservation like it definitely will
grow your
account right that makes sense tends to
be a lot more steady
you don't get the big ups and downs you
get you know solid
plus or minus two percent at the very
most in a day
usually something around there is the
like hedge against inflation like your
main reason
for like being convinced of it or is
there like something more that like
really changed your way of thinking and
being like oh this stuff is
worth putting money into yeah i think as
people are really adopting a digital
dollar
i think it's hard not to look at bitcoin
as just a store of value
that did it for me and and i would say
also maybe equally
just the inflation bit i just i really
believe that
our dollar at some point has to be
devalued the only reason it's not right
now is because nobody is spending money
and there are very few places spending
money like even here you can't walk down
the street
and and spend money to rest like almost
all of them are closed only a few of
them are doing delivery
um people aren't really traveling as
much so there is no
demand but there's not a lot of money
going into the economy to really cause
inflation right now
um i just think at some point give it a
few years
eventually people gotta return to normal
again they gotta start spending money
and i think at that point
uh we could see just the the dollar
losing its value i don't think it's
gonna be like you know venezuela
or anything but i i think it we could
see just
high inflation and the fed might go and
raise interest rates to help
calm that debt who knows what's going to
happen but everyone's very clueless
right now
it's a guess i mean that's just a guess
and i'm sure you could guess
a hundred times and one of those will
turn out to be correct that's just what
i think
i sort of uh it's funny i think it
happens with all the
finance channels but i sort of roll my
eyes because i'll see like one of your
videos where it's like stock market is
uh
going up or crashing or whatever it is
and i'm just like
oh like i cannot watch these videos
because it's just like
it all feels like uh i mean it obviously
is all speculation or whatever no
so in my videos i i almost never
speculate so all of those videos are
they take me like 10 hours yeah but the
thumbnail is speculation
no it's not really responsive responding
to a claim yeah economics
about that yes so it'll say like stock
market speaking but it was an article
so my video so yeah you use that as the
as the
place yeah you have to because if i'm
like stock market
update tuesday january so yeah nobody
will click on that but if i reference an
article saying
the stock market is a bubble exit now
yeah and you lead with that first of all
that that gets people even
to just click on it and watch and it's
like that people watch finance content
right
yeah yeah yeah yeah but my goal is to
always flip them around in the video so
they're clicking into it with the
expectation like is the stock market
going to collapse but then in the video
it's a well-researched perspective of
what happened what led up to this
and statistically what's likely to
happen because of that and what you
should do
but it's never like panic or now the
market is go and sell
um but that's a way to lead people in to
the point that gets them interested and
then
when they're in it you could give them
just practical information that they
could take away from so that's always
been my go-to but
yeah i i mean definitely the titles and
thumbnails like you have especially for
yeah you got to watch i will say like
financially you are not the worst
by any means you have you have really
nice
thumbnails that are compelling oh jesus
there are people who have
thumbnails that are basically like three
stocks you gotta buy
now but they won't say you gotta buy now
it'll be it'll be like a lot more
vague like three very lit stocks check
out yeah
three 10x stocks today um
so you are more of a real estate guy
yeah
you would your expertise i would say
until recent um i've really i felt like
in a way i've done like everything i
could in real estate for the most part
like i've got to a point where i feel
competent in it um it started to get
repetitive for me and now i've i've had
so much fun with either
just business in general or youtube that
makes sense
and you you don't have that many
properties do you have like
eight eight but they're la properties so
like one la property
yeah could be you know five other prices
yeah so that is one of the things that
people look at me and be like well he
only has eight but i have
50. but oftentimes my eight or when you
look at the dollar amount
it's it's it's a significant amount just
because it's in la yeah that makes sense
don't feel bad i don't think it's
impressive that they have a bunch of
units in yeah but
i don't know i've liked i've just liked
the creative expression of i think
business and youtube
and just i love coming up with ideas and
just
finding different ways to get your idea
out there and it makes me so happy when
things catch on like yada bank was
one of them where when i made that video
about yatta bank
i i don't know exactly how how much
value they got from that video i've been
telling jack this i mean
how many tens of millions of dollars in
value they went up because of of the
video
that i made they were the the top 10 it
was like forget what it was one of the
top trending apps
it was a number oh it was the number one
trending app on the google play store in
finance
for like a weekend after that video
because so many people downloaded i'm
like how much value did that add to the
company
what are you allowed to talk about the
like
uh nature of the deal like ever like how
much you invested or anything
i couldn't say unfortunately yeah okay
did you
at one point i'm sure if the ipo or
something happened i'm sure i'd be able
to
i really want to be able to talk about
that what about like um
was any part of it part of your like
or any any of the value
was the deal structured in such a way
that
you got more of something or
based on your video performance or
anything like that not like a
like kind of like a sponsor deal or
something like that not really
um i mean i did that's what makes me a
gotcha i'm just no no
no no i mean i do i do um there is a
referral link so people use my link to
sign up i do get credit for that
um but with these companies it becomes
so just
abstract to think what were they worth
before
if i post a video how much are they
worth afterwards
how much does that spread how much value
did i bring to them
and what was my cut on that and i have
no clue right right um
yeah you're just kind of saying i'm
lucky to be just being interested in
this thing
and from my perspective like i cared
more about just getting a good video out
i didn't even think like i was unsure
that video would do well i just want to
get a good video out there
share something that like just different
from my normal con like i was more
excited about that
but then i started thinking to myself
like how much value is there in this
because i'd never seen that before
and then i'm starting to think like if
if another company were to come to me in
the future
that that i could do something so how
much is that like i don't know
yeah so it's just it's a new world and
um
and so i'm valuing more now instead of
getting money i just want equity
like that's and that's something that i
think going forward in this year it's
like
i don't want the money anymore i just
want the equity i want to take a chance
on a company that i really believe in
if it turns out to be nothing fine but
if it turns out to hit great
but i'd rather stand behind just
something that i really would use myself
so you do all your business deals
yourself yeah okay you don't have any
sort of brand manager or anything like
that no
general brand manager yeah no oh uh
kind of like part-time so they just
present you with deals and you
okay like and you also if you get
emailed directly from the company you'll
also negotiate that way yeah
you won't send it to your brand manager
uh no you guys don't uh
uh turn these into highlights do you no
we will once we hit a hundred thousand
subscribers we're at ninety thousand
we're going to hit it like
is there a reason you guys are i feel
like you would hit a hundred thousand
a lot quicker than you have graham
doesn't shout out on his main channel
okay i feel like there are too many
things for me to mention
and i'm like i mentioned the second
usually i like
i like them finding it more again i
think that's exactly right i've been
doing the exact same thing
for my twitch channel um i that way you
get
the most fervent people in your comment
section to start
you lay a really good foundation and
then that's when the floodgates get out
he sends him to the second channel and
yeah second channel he sends him here so
there's a filter the second channel the
people are so dedicated on there but the
podcast
i think our view to subscriber ratio is
so
high on the podcast with about ninety
thousand subscribers the videos will
usually get instantly get nearly 150 to
like 250 000 views
so like i like that ratio that more
people are watching it than even
subscribe but the people who are
subscribed are like
the the dedicated just he shouted out
the end
of the like a 17-18 yeah like a second
conversion rate at the end my theory is
that the people who make it to the very
end
are most likely actually so like why
waste a pitch
pitching to someone who's just gonna get
aggravated like why is he pitching me
at the very end at least they're more
receptive to it and those are the people
most likely to do it anyway so it's like
i'm not going to waste a pitch on
someone who doesn't want to hear it so
that's good
that's super valuable i think that makes
sense yeah i know i'm very anti-sales uh
when it comes to a lot of things like
something like like the weeble plugs
i'll do them just like
tongue and cheeks you can get your feet
for free stocks right you gotta feel it
funny sort of yeah but i'll never be
like
really like seriously pitching i just i
don't like it
it irks me especially in finance just
like the finance guy trying to pitch you
on something
just has a bad connotation to it so i
just avoid it
um okay so this is a question
that um i mean i think a younger me
would have
for i think both of you uh
it seems like a lot of what you guys do
is
very daunting at the start like the way
you talk about real estate it's just
like
second nature now but obviously when you
got started
i imagine it was a lot more daunting
it's crazy
is there a like i guess a method or
like a thought process that you had when
you were younger
that helped you like get past these like
really daunting moments where it's like
you you have the idea of getting into
real estate like what is the next step
and like because i often feel like if i
want to do something like that i'll
watch a youtube video and now i have 10
more questions about it
yeah uh for me it was really doing it
firsthand i had a really amazing t-shirt
when i first started
uh real estate and this was just by a
random stroke of luck people have heard
the story a million times
uh but when i was like turning 18 years
old i'd go to open houses
every single sunday and i would just go
and meet with real estate agents and
ask their advice and i was basically
just turned 18 like barely 18
walking in to like five million dollar
houses in bellaire like i just went to
the homes
that were over like three four million
dollars because i figured if i'm gonna
sell real estate i'm just gonna sell the
most expensive ones and i talked to
those agents
and after months of doing that just one
agent took me under his wing just by
random luck and uh basically said that
you could come work underneath me
uh whatever business you do i will split
50 50
and uh just i'll help you out with this
so he had me doing just his
all the grunt work that just like people
wouldn't even
want to get paid for i did it for free
because i just wanted to learn but this
was like going and setting up his open
houses
putting open house signs um dealing with
a horrible just
the worst his worst most difficult
clients that were wasting time he just
sent me
um because he didn't want to ruin that
relationship with the client but he knew
they're just like wasting time
um and so i just happened to get in
through that he was a great teacher but
i remember in the beginning he showed me
like
escrow paperwork and it's like this
thick of just disclosures and i'm like i
have to know all of that how do i fill
out those forms
it took me probably like two years to
really get good and like feel
comfortable
like fill out my own form online without
having somebody else review it
um the thing the thing like you the way
you described it at the start it was
like
i just went to open houses i feel like
for a lot of people
that would it would not be that easy
wouldn't just be like i'll go to an open
house and learn as much as i can
ears wide open it's like do you feel
like you might be wired a little bit
differently that that wasn't
too daunting and even talking how old
were you
uh 18 18. yeah yeah being freshly 18
i would not feel remotely confident
enough to walk into an open house
especially in
bel air and just start talking to like a
real estate agent i was weird
i don't know i've always felt like an
old soul like i've always felt like deep
down i'm like 80 years old
yeah um but uh like it's weird i always
felt like very socially awkward with
people my age
but for some reason i could get along
with people in the interesting 40s and
50s
uh even as a kid i remember like my mom
would take me to uh
like like in in kindergarten whatever
like first grade take me to these like
play dates
i would not play with the other kids at
all like i just would look at them and
be like what are they doing that's weird
i just just are you an online child yeah
i have a half sister
but she's 18 years older than me so i
never really grew up with a sibling
uh but i would just hang with the adults
like i just never got what
all the other kids were doing um then
when i was like 13
i got a part-time job working at this
marine aquarium wholesaler because i was
really into aquariums oh i've heard this
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah and that's where i spent like
i i through that weird phase
uh of a few years like i really didn't
have many friends and it was just like i
just loved working
like that would like i would hang out
with people at work like we had this guy
andy
um i don't know how old andy was at the
time maybe mid-30s or something but like
he really took me under his wing and
like would go get lunch and talk like
fish and aquariums and stuff like that
and the owner chris
uh we'd have these great talks and chris
would teach me like how to talk on the
phone to customers and like what to say
and how to
bag up the coral and the fish and when
to put the heat packs in and the cool
packs
so you were just all ears you're just
listening i loved it i loved it but i
couldn't go and like hang out with kids
my own age because it just
it didn't click even now it's like i'd
much rather
like work than i would like go to a
party or like it's i'm so
weird in social settings like that but
like business
i could zone in on it like i just love
that have you gone to therapy or
anything like that yeah
you have do you think that's a valuable
thing um
i've never gone for there for that um
just for just
oh yeah i'm i'm sorry not necessarily
for a thing
i mean yeah specifically that thing i
was just wondering like just
oh in general yeah i have yeah yeah okay
yeah a lot of that i think is trying to
find like just balance
usually when i get into something i go
like head first like it's right all i
want to do
work um but part of me is just like i
just love it so like
is it a problem maybe um but like i
love it so much that i feel like it
would be taking away a portion of like
who i am as a person if i didn't
work so like i love i guess the way i
see it that
what you are like the things that you
like to do like lines up very much with
like what our society has
like deemed the right things to do or
whatever
and you're just like oh yeah i love like
maximizing you know
value and all this sort of stuff and
schmoozing with
people 30 years old but i've been like
that
since i was a kid yeah even like i got
into collecting coins my grandpa showed
me his coin collection when i was like
four or five and
then what i would do is when my parents
would come home they'd take the change
and i'd look through like all the coins
and i had this big book like this red
it's like the red coin book or something
and i'd look at the pennies in the years
and be like okay this penny's worth like
five cents and this nickel
this is a 1945 nickel so it's like 90
percent silver so i'm gonna put this one
aside like i keep them
yeah you're getting panicked uh same
with pokemon cards like i got so many i
was collecting
i was gonna ask you about that i noticed
that you
bought you bought a logan paul i did
yeah how much was that eleven
thousand one hundred and eleven dollars
and eleven cents
uh what what do you categorize that
spending as terrifying
no not terrifying where is that worst
investment of your life do you call it
an investment um
you call it a shout out that was an
investment for me yeah i looked at that
from a very
uh financial standpoint when i saw his
video and i saw he had packs come up i'm
like okay i'm going to spend 11 thousand
dollars what am i going to get back in
return well i can make a video on it
just making a video on it is kind of
enough yeah so that'll make the money
back if i just make a video but then i'm
thinking well i could make a video on
anything and it would make the same
amount of money so now i'm really just
spending 11 000
for a shout out from logan paul well
that's not gonna do much uh but then i'm
gonna spend 11 000 to make the
connection
how much is that worth and then i get
the cards so i
really looked at this like the risk
of buying and spending 11 grand was
probably worth it
knowing that i get to make a video get
to
network um and then i have the cards
yeah and then it's just interesting
content
that makes and uh yeah pulled the
gyarados so
that made the money back yeah did you
buy from pokerev as well do you know who
that is i did
yeah didn't you get the gyarados from
pokerev no no
no i uh so pogirev i bought a uh first
edition neogenesis
and then it turned out to be a fake
pattern i watched that video
that was crazy yeah that was one of
those
very few live streams i'm like glued to
my phone and i'm like oh
my god that was so cool i was like man
this guy should get more fake boxes
because that was entertaining
yeah i told them by the way um i don't
know if i i guess we'll put it
i told them to send it to uh you say
it's a psa
to see if they would grade it and to see
if they like
couldn't detect this as a fake who knows
i think he's going to do i just see but
but if it comes back like graded
then all the psa cards i think are kind
of now yeah that's scary
that's really scary yeah they're all
there's no way they don't detect that
yeah i'm thinking about it it's like
that if anyone would know
their process because that would [ __ ]
them yeah like it has to be they're
probably better than writing cards
than the people how good the people are
at creating fake cards
it's a lot of i mean that was a lot of
work making those fake cards
because they were close i know yeah so
we'll see and they can't do things like
the rip test and stuff like that
imagine just ribbing and then putting
tape together
yeah but uh but yeah thankfully the
logan paul thing
really worked out pulled the gyarados
made my money back on that
and then i put the other cards on ebay
and i used all those proceeds to donate
towards nami
oh cool yes that was a leonhardt
organization yeah whatever yeah yeah so
exactly so my plan
was just at least um at the very like
the worst case scenario i could donate a
good chunk of that back to charity
uh so did that uh met logan paul he's
really nice
and um gosh what's that and then that's
led me to so many other connections like
we met uh gary
king pokemon uh we got an amazing
uh just connection through him uh
learned a lot about pokemon he
introduced us to steve aoki
um and just you never know where these
things might lead so i'd say for eleven
thousand
that was money really well spent yeah
and even if i pulled you know it's
yourself the logan paul video did really
well
yeah so yeah that's a good gamble to
take it's just like the idea of like
video pays it off okay everything extra
is going on i'll tell you the only bad
investment that i've fit that made me
hesitant about this was i spent eight
thousand dollars on tesla full
self-driving
just so that i could make a video on it
and i asked them ahead of them i'm like
is there any way i could get this like
sponsored
no is there anyone i could get a
discount on it no but it's full
self-driving
not worth it what yeah yeah it's still
in beta mode
like it's not the greatest yeah oh yeah
you're gonna you're gonna still have it
once
yeah that's true but i spent eight grand
on this and the video
bombed it was one of my worst performing
videos
and i think i think i mean two grand
back i would have never had used it i
didn't need it
it's right now it's not that cool so i
keep looking at that video i'm like that
was a waste of money but you never
sometimes they hit and sometimes they
don't one thing that i want to mention
to address your question as well because
i think i'm in a little bit of a
different situation than graham
like i didn't find myself inherently
drawn to investing or anything like that
although i've been investing now for
over 10 years
which sounds fishy because i'm only 22.
right but
interestingly enough like some events
that happened when i was really young
like 10
11 kind of forced me to start investing
so i actually started investing at a
really young age and i wouldn't say that
like
i would have i would not say that
naturally i would have
involved myself investing in investing
if this hadn't happened
but it was just because of like my
parents they are like really into
investing or my dad is and he would tell
me all about it
and i think that led to me like kind of
having an easier
in to investing and i would say if that
wasn't for there i don't think i would
have naturally been drawn to it
right that makes sense wait so you were
you were investing when you were how old
11 11 my 11th birthday yeah what was
your first like uh
thing you did i think i bought apple
yeah yeah
that's probably a good time huh yeah
that's awesome but that that's like
to to show that like maybe not everyone
is like inherently
right interested in investing but
there's external things that can kind of
lead you to want to invest which is what
i hope
that like graham's channel has done for
a lot of people and i bet it has that's
a great point
i totally agree with that i think it i i
mean i think a lot of people are that
way
yeah you know you could teach them how
to do it and you get more excited as you
go along with it
absolutely for sure yeah i've definitely
been that way over the you know past
five years i've been to you know
like before that i was just kind of uh
you know trying to
get a day job kind of thing and it's
like that's gonna be the
income and then now that you have the
day job it's like figure out what to do
with your extra money scary
yeah like i i get all my friends none of
them are interested in finance so it was
always me just talking with my dad
and i try to get them to invest but you
know they're not working like crazy jobs
or anything
and they're so scared to do it right and
like wow i never had to deal with that
because like i was just forced into i
can't even remember what it was like to
make my first investment right
like that was just just i was so lucky
that's really all it came down to was
just luck to be shown wall street bets
are you on there i've heard a lot about
that
oh i don't know like it just sounds like
it's mostly memes
like a lot of memes but some of these
sought like game stop was one of their
recent calls
and uh they've probably i don't know
6xed
that price of well
so people are like seriously just like
following the subreddit and just being
like yes
whatever they say and put money in
correct do they give like
the original poster do they give like a
solid breakdown no
so what ends up happening is that
someone will post what's known as like
dd
due diligence and they'll come up with
these like just crazy things of just
saying like this is in a short squeeze
and this is about to
come up and then uh what ends up
happening is you start getting these
memes that get made
and the more popular it is the more
people buy into it which causes the
price to rise up and then there's a
price rising up then people post their
gains
and then you see people like and then
more people buy it and it keeps driving
up the price gamestop was one of those
there's been quite a few
uh previously it was tesla and uh people
have started making these
bots that will comb the algorith that
will come the
subreddit and pick up how many times
certain stocks are mentioned and it'll
uh it'll come up with a list of just
like the top most
uh talked about stocks last like 24
hours and then you could trade based off
that it's
but when you have a community of like
two three million people who
all are following like the same stocks
they do have an impact on the market at
least short term i think long term no
but i think over the next like week or
two
they can't but also some of these just
lose money a lot of them lose money or
if you
don't time it right i mean it's really
everything is hail mary it's just like
i'll put my life savings into like yes
but it's really entertaining yeah the
community is actually that jokes
yeah i follow it really closely because
uh
they not only do they actually post like
good information
but some of the like the loopholes they
find like they found the robin hood
infinite money loophole and they they
found this glitch in robin hood before
it was like even a thing
and then just everyone exploited it
right afterwards like and
robin was trying to like fix uh these
these
exploits that wall street to figure it
out and so they're the ultimate test for
some of these brokerages like if you
could survive this you're good
it's crazy the power that wall street
bets has and now robin hood has more
users than td ameritrade
and you know like all the robinhood
people are like the wall street bad
people something just pumped up a stock
yeah definitely yeah we're definitely i
feel like they can move markets dude
but if we're just in the beginning of
this whole fintech thing i just think
this is fintech is going to be i think
at some point like the green energy
is becoming now i think it's already
going in that direction but i think
personal finance is going to be trendy
saving money is going to be trendy
investing is going to be cool
like look at all the high schoolers they
get to invest their money like i think
at some point
maybe it's just like some dystopian idea
that i have but that i would like to see
but i just think like middle schoolers
will look up to the high school be like
oh look they're trading on robin hood
look how cool that
i think i think it'll be like that one
it could be that
the culture has to change though it's
like but it is yeah yeah we're like a
consumer in
consumerism no i think we're no the
savings rate
lately has been going on because i need
to spend it before then the last few
years the savings rate has increased
and i think just people are getting more
thrifty i think just we went through a
horrible time where millennials
graduated a lot of debt
uh just got saddled with a crap job
market and they really had to take
matters into their own hands so i think
now people are really realizing the
importance of personal finance
it could happen it's going i just feel
like it's uh it's
uh leveraged more toward the older crowd
in general because you i mean
everyone's an idiot who's like under 18.
so i don't feel like
not yeah sure yeah yeah yeah like in
general
it's like always going to be an old
person's game maybe
i don't know older maybe yeah what's
your opinion on people
going straight into like investing and
stuff like that and it being scary
oh yeah like it really is it's weird
i kind of relate to your uh sentiment
about like getting into it early
where you had this role model of your
dad who like
didn't wasn't fearful about it and
wasn't like oh be careful or whatever i
mean maybe it was to an extension
okay but uh it just it
it instills a level of confidence that
you need to start investing to make
these decisions
because i like i'll sit on td
ameritrade's website and just like
ponder decision like for hours and
should be like should i be doing this
like i don't know and it's just like
it's completely fine
like even if i was putting into an index
or whatever like it's totally fine i
just i'm afraid to even transfer money
oftentimes because it's like
what if it gets lost in between i get
paid
in here the same thing i will always
transfer five or ten dollars first
even though i know the accounts linked
just to make sure it goes through and
then i'm like okay now i can do the rest
all the time yeah i actually had it
happen once before i transferred a
hundred thousand dollars like 150 grand
from bank of america to i it was like a
chase or something like that
the wire was lost i kid you not
it was the scariest moment of my life
150 grand and i forget what it was but
there was like
something that wasn't correct and i
forget if it was on bank of america's
part or like i
oh oh i i mixed up the account number
and the routing number
like something something like that got
mixed up and it got sent to the wrong
spot
try reaching someone at bank of america
try it
you can't do i was on the hold for like
two hours trying to reach somebody in
the wire department
and then by the time i reached them the
department was closed and then i had to
call them back the next day
and try to trace down this wire and it
was it was gut wrenching but like five
days later the money showed back in the
account because they told me like
we we can't do anything because it's
it's out of our hands so that's scary so
the only thing we could do
is wait for it to get rejected and then
it's going to come back and i had to
just
wait for it to be rejected which took
days
horrible horrible i i just mentally i
was it's such a such a bad mood
but it's scary so since then i will
never send a wire with bank of america
ever again
um i will only do ach transfers for some
reason i find that to be
just safer yeah scary stuff i think the
idea
and graham and i have talked about this
before but the idea of losing money
is scarier than like being happy to make
money yeah you know what i mean
there's a bigger difference yeah you
work for your money
and people just don't have that
certainty like in investing in the
market that they will get
good returns right i try to like tell
myself and
anissa and even my parents like hey look
at the
like smp like that just kind of has been
doing that
sort of thing like seems pretty like if
you were within that period of time like
it's it's all gravy um so i'm like
trying to like instill some confidence
saying like
yeah this stuff is okay yeah it's not
you know it's not going to explode
what's a niece's view on personal
finance investing do you guys do you
guys talk about yeah like finances and
we try to talk about it a little bit
it's uh she's less into it than i am
obviously like i kind of have a
for it like you do we're just like i'm
spending my free time
looking at stuff yep um but i you know
i'd say more average like he's like
and your average maybe one of your
viewers i don't know now your viewers
are actually a little bit crazier i
think
viewers are probably above average yeah
yeah so like imagine you watching just
minus yeah
don't invest as much don't save as much
and i i think she's just in general more
focused on
living like a happy life like
realizing at what point like the money
is like
good to live your life and like not
going beyond that
sort of thing like because there's
really like in our in her mind there's
no point in like chasing a bigger
bank and you think that's affected you
because during the interview you said
that like 100 000 you kind of
yeah yeah yeah i feel the same so you
naturally feel the same it wasn't an
effect of hers
um oh she's had an influence on me for
sure it's just like it's something i've
thought about i've heard that like stat
before i think it
i think it's like two different levels
based on this study like maybe 60 or 70
000 is like yeah it's diminishing like
happiness returns yeah for a certain age
i don't i don't know how i don't want to
say like i don't know
i think it's super valid and a perfect
example is this
like when i looked at how much before
coming over here how much i spent for
the year and it was like 40 000. i'm
like
man i'm doing a lot of crazy in the year
like i've only spent 40
000 like and that's that's including
everything that's like my mortgage and
all that
um i'm like this is crazy if i was on a
you know
like a pretty nice salary of like i
don't know 80 000 i'd be like
living no differently really i think all
that this allows me to do
like having the big bank account is to
not give a [ __ ] and do these crazy
investments and be like oh i'll still be
fine
i'll still be fine a little rich getting
richer sort of thing um
but yeah i think once you once you hit
that threshold
like where you you're gonna be different
but i think once you can start saying
like uh yeah just throw the you know
pasta sauce in the uh
in the uh shopping cart like i don't
care what price it is it's all roughly
the same
two i still like two to ten dollars
that's powerful right there
yeah i mean it's it's one of those
things i feel like if you can do that
that's like about as good as it's ever
gonna get
you know i don't think everyone should
like use that as their barometer like
like bill gates on the price is right
like not knowing what
normal things cost it's still i think
good to have an idea
of what money's doing but i think to not
stress about these little
things is exactly what you like exactly
the benefit you get from having a big
cushion
i agree i would say i'm no i'm no
happier now than i was
right maybe eight years ago but it just
having the means not to
necessarily let i oh i do let the money
dictate
a lot of things like restaurants for
example like i will i don't look at what
the item is i'll look at what the price
is first
and then i'll decide what to eat based
on like this is
14 but that's 18. let me do the 14 and
then i'll see what else is 14. i'll pick
based on that
it's like more of a game for you though
yeah but it's not even necessarily like
you don't think you can afford that it's
more like
i'm going to it just seems to choose the
value
option it seems wasteful i don't know
what it is it just
it seems wasted you're paying someone's
uh wage
that's why i love the door dash and
stuff so much it's like
three dollar tip five dollar tip there
and it
doesn't feel like anything to me but
some of that could be passed on with the
cost
like a stake would cost more than let's
say a salad so maybe the profit margin
on the salad is actually
higher for less money than the steak it
could be
so yeah sometimes they make less money
on the more expensive items yeah yeah
so but uh but yeah i just think you're
in a position where you could
it's not don't think of it as like
splurging think of it as you putting
like
uh more money into things that you enjoy
in a like a practical way rather than
necessarily like investing yeah
the only thing that i've well two things
i bought myself a piano that was a big
thing
that piano i showed you in the picture
and an aquarium yeah so that's getting
built in
february so that the aquarium is
something i'm looking forward to the
most
yeah it's so like saltwater saltwater
three it turned out so it was
originally gonna start at like 150
gallons then it went to 250 and it went
to 305 gallons
why did it keep going up uh i mean when
i looked at the size of it originally it
was gonna be five feet long and i'm like
well it's
six feet long looks better yeah it's not
gonna make it yeah exactly so you're
gonna have to maintain it either way
and then it's like when you get depth to
the aquarium when you look at it and you
want the rock working
in the center then it's important to be
33 inches instead of 28.
because getting that extra few inches is
really going to make it look just a lot
more natural
and then the height 29 inches high so
yeah i do have a question for you ian it
seems like you're more excited about
investing
your money than you are about scaling
your income because you said like it
doesn't matter after a certain amount
but for some reason you see really
you seem really fixated on uh investing
and stuff like that yeah
it's just something that i haven't like
really done and i think
i'm sort of like uh really wide-eyed
about it right now because all my
investments are doing well
so it's like that is obviously like
encouraging me quite a bit
um but i still think there's just a lot
of general stuff to learn
and um i just i think i eventually want
to either share
the information with other people people
friends and family to maybe help them if
they're not like a different position
i don't yeah i genuinely don't feel like
i'm earning
uh um like you could not make anymore
doing youtube videos and you could like
oh yeah yeah oh yeah definitely yeah uh
that's okay i see what you're saying
you're saying
like i i could make a lot more if i just
invested more time
on the youtube stuff and scaling up or
making a business yeah probably if you
look at
just the numbers you probably make more
money just scaling up the channel like
just double down millions a year
yeah i'm certain on that yeah
yeah i don't i don't know what it is i
just
don't like um
i just feel like i've made enough on
there you know what i mean
i like that that's so that's cool yeah
what flipped
did you get to a point where he's like
all right i've kind of done it
um did it get repetitive what
no i mean i think graeme you're making
it sound like i'm quitting youtube
or something right like i'm not quitting
that i really enjoy that a lot
the like drive for the um
money it's just like i'm i'm realizing
that there are other ways to earn money
so
it's really encouraging to me that i
could maybe make whatever i want on
youtube
without having to worry about the money
ramifications and get
like a you know source of income from
somewhere else because i'm mainly i
think worried about just like
youtube my youtube either you know
losing
a viewership or just ad rates going down
or whatever
yeah being poor and just being like i
could keep doing it yeah
how monetizable are you on youtube like
what's your cpm
i i don't know to be honest it you don't
know how much we check this out
daily can we check your analytics yeah
yeah
oh wow we asked all of our guests this
is exciting
dude do people usually yeah everyone
else yeah this is it i don't know what
you want to see here
i want to see the real time what do you
think about that
you lost 10 000 yeah subscribers in 28
days
yeah yeah that's uh that's just been a
slow grind i'm like purging a lot of
people from my audience i think with my
uh
oh it was from i think it's it's a
carryover
from me and my girlfriend announcing her
only fans
and there were a lot of fans who were
really disappointed about that
so dumb so they've just been like just
every month there's just like a new
group who's like
he's changed oh jeez okay click up there
and then
go to analytics i want to see okay so
your real-time views
are 560 000 steady
yeah go to uh go to like 90.
fair enough when you post there's a big
spike yeah but you do have consistent
views
overall in the last 90 days 28 million
yeah yeah i don't look why
it's just meaningless but it's not
though when you when you start going
digging into this
scroll down this is basically how you
make it on youtube like this this is
what we pay all the attention to
okay so your cbm is six dollars and
fifty cents meaning that your rpm
is about 325 which is i will say
one of the lowest that we've seen yes
i will will you say that's the lowest
probably either that or michael reeves
and i'm guessing it's just due to the
swearing yeah
yeah interesting i think we got our
information we needed yeah thank you
very much that was wait
wait let me show you my audience look at
is that 89.
like four percent i think so yeah let me
see
um what about yeah let's see geographies
okay so yours is actually a pretty
marketable audience
you want over fifty percent from the
united states and they'll give you high
cbms and sponsors my female audience is
growing 14
female oh yeah yeah nice well
like most of the audience just on
youtube is male 1 disproportionately
by a lot right so factor that in
definitely yeah
i like it your analytics are actually
really good they're very thanks man
and you don't post that much it's
impressive yeah well okay so
graham you were saying i i am under the
impression
let me let me rephrase what i said
before i don't think it's completely
useless information
okay i think it's good from like a very
kind of pulled
out macro perspective of like okay where
things headed
it's good to check in maybe every couple
of months or something like that
no that's where i'm that's where i'm at
with okay to us this is as micro as you
could get
we and this to me that's your blueprint
to everything on youtube
it's interesting how some youtubers are
crazy about their analytics and some
just aren't
yeah if you enjoy it like you guys
obviously enjoy it
you know to us it's a game of uh like
chess it's like trying to
match with the algorithm and be like
what is it gonna like what's gonna hit
it feels so good
when like everything lines up and it
just hits yeah
um yeah i i agree i think
maybe the way that i'm different is i
only like playing the game
when i feel like playing it rather than
saying like every time i
upload it needs to be like uh
you know i need to like monitor them the
metrics of it or whatever
sure um like nato brian
yeah but nate o'brien nato brian just
like that yeah
very relaxed about their youtube yeah
but they do so but he's doing so well
i think they're i mean it's one of those
things where it's just i mean
it's the difference between getting a b
plus and an
a but since you do only post one you
really feel inspired to
maybe the content that you do put out
like is just overall better because you
don't feel
forced to continuously put out content
well yeah i was also thinking there's a
bit of that i think part of the reason i
don't put out as much
is because people are more willing
they're not inundated with me
um there's a lot of channels that are
like i need to post every day and
i know my reaction to a lot of these
channels is i don't watch you
because i can't keep up with it or i've
seen
way too much of you so i try to put
myself
out in like small spurts it's one of the
reasons i didn't want to like do live
streaming for a long time because i
didn't want to put myself out there
that frequently because i don't want
people to get tired of what i have to
say
i feel like that yeah i yeah yeah i get
nervous about that since we are posting
daily you know
i've enjoyed it but it's different
audiences daily between three channels
it's
a different game there are some people
i mean yeah it's different for every
channel i think you you can do it more
because you actually have like
content to give to people like you have
like you're looking over things you're
reviewing things
yeah when you're reviewing stuff like i
would feel comfortable
like doing it all the time if i was
reviewing stuff it wasn't necessarily
about me all the time it wasn't me
focused
a lot of it is pretty like me focused
but see i don't know i feel like with
you
you're someone i'm i'm jealous of in the
sense that you could talk about anything
and i would watch it like
anything and i've always wanted to get
to that point where i could talk about
like
this candle here and and people would
want to hear me talk about the candle
your save the squirrels initiative i
i've seen
basically all of your squirrel videos i
don't know why it's just
really entertaining and just you talking
about catching the the black squirrel
or like the what's the world like
peanuts yeah listen that was one
and everyone would just watch because
it's i think it's more about you
than it is the content at this point
right
yeah i think you might have a point it's
hard for me to like self-reflect on it
and like really figure it out i think
the only thing i've like
grabbed onto is like infrequent posting
i feel like that's like kind of the only
measurable metric i can
it's like michael he posts once every
like two three months
you know drama and it's like whenever he
puts out a video
like i'm so excited yeah you're kind of
starved but if he did it yeah you know
every week then i'd i'd probably miss a
few years his videos are so intricate
he couldn't really do in my like i don't
know if he had a team he could
but i'm talking about a sit down video
like his videos
i watch because they're so just like i
can't believe he just did that or made
that like that's
genius and it's funny um i don't think
i've seen him just do a sit down
like just a straight sit down talk no
definitely not no
so that's why michael reeves i feel like
he can only po like even if he worked 24
7 like i feel like maybe he could post
like every other week with what he's
doing maybe
i do have a question ian um graham tells
me that he thinks it's good and he
encourages me to have an insta story
running 24 7.
i completely disagree and i post on my
instagram
maybe once every three weeks and i post
on my like feed
once every month at the most and graham
says you gotta have it constantly
running to engage people but i think
like i get so sick when people have
their feed running
all the time because i feel like i'm
drowning in it you know and i like
i don't know it's gonna depend for the
type of consumer i think
i think there are some people who like
are really like on it and engaged i try
to think
from like like i'm the only person who
like
like like i just base it off of like
what i feel about these like ins
you're saying instagram stories yeah
okay so like
there are people whose instagram stories
who are like so
long like those it's all little dots
then you just go and swipe through yeah
i don't do that right but i mean
there are people who are on there every
day but it's like it's
kind of it just depends on who you're
going for like i find it a treat i
follow
pewdiepie on instagram and it's kind of
a treat to see what he's up to
occasionally if he was doing something
every day it wouldn't be very
like special yeah so it's
it's tough i don't like have great
judgment for people who
like but that's another thing is like
pewdiepie isn't my bread and butter
on instagram stories right like there
are other people who
i will check up on more regularly and
see what they're doing
but it's it's hard it just depends on
what type of viewer you are
there are like gaming channels that i
watch to get you know 20 000 views per
video
and it's like uh uh
well now i'm struggling because i don't
want to underestimate the amount of
views they get
and say oh it's this channel no but i
watch a lot of hearthstone streamers
so preparing barbarian trunks uh
uh disguise toast yes those are the guys
i used to watch back from day all the
time i love hearthstone yeah yeah
yeah i play a lot of hearthstone
battlegrounds um
and so i watch their stuff when i'm like
falling asleep at night
but that's like daily they get like a
lot of watch time for me
and but like i'm not
that's to kill the time basically i'm
not going to their channel saying like
what's next preparing video to watch
it's just kind of like you know i know
he's uploaded
something today like he uploads twice a
day or whatever it is it makes sense
see i told jack like like we you know
how we talked about that filter
it goes main channel second channel
podcast
takes the last
so the people who follow jack on
instagram are like the
people that will do anything jack says
jump and they say how high
yeah but i told i told jack it would be
a fun idea to post
editing clips like as he's editing the
second channel just always have a clip
running where people could tune in and
see the behind the scenes of just like
what's the next video you're working on
or just
seeing all things like that i think are
fun and when you always have a story
running i've noticed
instagram tends to prioritize your
stories above everybody else
the more engagement your stories get the
further up you show
on the list so is that just that works
generally interesting yeah you don't
post that much no instagram
ever instagram sucks dude
i hate instagram why it's just boring
there's like nothing on there for me
i saw you have tick tock dude i saw you
when you had like a couple
like literally so few followers do you
still have a few followers oh that's
funny dude do you still have a few
people yeah i have like maybe a thousand
yeah dude i saw you when you had like
100 seconds no i literally think i saw
you when you had double digit followers
and i was like what i was like bonnie
how was ian on here
and there were comments saying like did
we just find ian's tick tock with like
20 followers
yeah it's uh you ain't gonna find it the
tradition how do i find
your name is so weird it's uh i think
it's happy grooky
happy what uh grooky
g r o o k y
99 are you happy that you like are small
on there yeah
well it's the same logic with twitch or
whatever it's just like only the hyper
fans or people who are like
really like paying attention will find
it yeah
i uh yeah i just made that i made a
stupid tick tock at the time i've been
on tiktok for
almost since it's been around basically
um
and i finally like last year made the
account
and i just hadn't told anyone about it i
was like oh yeah like i have like
three videos now which is nothing but it
is really funny to see people either
coming from a niece's channel or
like just randomly coming across i get
so excited like when i found it i was
like i found it
yeah it's just like you find gold how
did you find it dude
uh something dad yeah it was dax yeah
yeah i
i reacted or i do edited one of jack's
videos
uh dax was like uh uh react to this
video
um uh and he was like telling a joke he
was like i want to
test out this joke to see if it's any
good yeah
and you like or something yeah that's
funny
yeah it was just funny yeah dax is still
doc is really
tick tocks are probably my favorite yeah
oh yeah it's so funny
yeah i have a hard time getting into
tick tock i need you to post
dude dick dog's awesome you would do
really well on tick tock he has i have
he has one video with like over 10
million
no it's almost at like 70. why wouldn't
you just keep grinding on that i didn't
like it
money man yeah that's where the money is
there's no and if you get big enough
they have the creator
i'm a part of the creator fund okay uh
17 million views on that video
what'd you do would you talk about how
much money i made on youtube
oh it's a pretty easy video to make it
was a it was a one minute video
ryan uh penito who's on the podcast told
me that if i made that video it's gonna
get a million views and i'm like okay
fine i'll make the video and we'll see
how it does
uh it got i think like 14 million views
in like two days
and i had so many people reach out to me
because of that tick tock
i was shocked yeah it's like a whole new
audience yeah
yeah but just people who like the the
vlog squad
was so like they saw that tick tock i
was like what but they knew me
not from youtube yeah but from the tick
tock yeah i was
blown away but i'll show you how much i
made this is the first time i think i'm
revealing my
yes tick tock revenue it's gonna blow
your brain here's how much i made
yesterday oh wait here is this it so i
made 32 cents
on the 16th view dashboard okay so so
far i made 737
and i make between livable 30 and 63
cents a day
that's so weird how much money do they
have to give away to people i think
that's such a big
deal not very much it's like four cents
when the video was taken off
that one day made 216 dollars that's
great and that i think
was on uh seven million views that day
some
something absurd what's your guys's take
on like uh
youtube premium i like it because you
can uh
close your phone yeah you can lock it up
that's the best part uh american express
offered a streaming credit so i use that
credit for youtube premium
worth it actually i really like it um
yeah
also for the uh ads the
yeah the what what you get from viewers
watching your stuff with youtube premium
i don't know i've uh youtube premium is
really that's maybe like three percent
that makes sense
with me it's like closer to half wow
yeah yeah
makes sense i'm super into it for that
reason because i'm like
oh yeah why wouldn't any everyone
promote youtube premium but why then
why couldn't you just do the creator uh
that what is it the monthly subscription
the creator thing what's it called uh
membership
memberships uh because you have to offer
something with membership no you don't
i mean you don't but you probably should
little icons i have icons
people wait you don't even stream on
youtube and you make people
in the make yes i force people i force
people no they don't
they icons when they come in here's the
thing we all like they get icons when
they come yeah such an active one
they could use those icons even when
they're not live streaming
only in uh for my videos well no yeah
just they comment on one of my videos
and they get an icon it's pretty awesome
and for people
okay icons are good the thing is for
people want to stand out in the comment
section if you're scrolling you're more
likely to read the comments with like a
little lotus excuse next to it yeah
i like that okay i might i might do that
yeah that's cool
so people like it did they give you
anything else other than the icons
man i think it's they make that more
compelling
because that's they they need to offer
more because i feel like they
could yeah well i could um but like that
that's just for what if
you want the icons it's there if they
don't if they don't then so be it but i
feel like everyone would make more money
because like like the youtuber doesn't
want to add more responsibility on their
already busy schedule yeah so if you can
add like a default thing that just
happens
like that is rad yeah the issue with
with that
i think youtube takes like 45 of it
that's the only negative
aspect of it uh because otherwise you
just go to like patreon or something
um or you start an only fans yeah i
could be have you thought about that
i have genuinely considered what would
you post on there
uh man just waggling like around i don't
know would you actually
i mean yeah that's all insane
just curious yeah i mean again i'm not
uh i made my position on i'm pretty
clear like i'm not
opposed to it at all like i don't it's
one of those things it doesn't
particularly interest me if i had like
an intro i've since my girlfriend has
done it i've
like started to like look into the app
more and see how it works and i'm like
more interested in that scene
in general there's like a lot of money
to be made oh geez
you've been working out a lot haven't
you thanks for noticing dude
you know yeah yeah i've been lifting
yeah yeah so i
feel like you could be a pretty hot
topic on the a hot commodity
thank you i appreciate that of course
man what if your girlfriend gets jealous
that you're on the app yeah you
earn more than that yeah yeah i mean
that's the possibility
she does and then all of a sudden you
would make attention in the relationship
you really would
thanks dude i think i might i think i
might actually it would be funny
like yeah cosplay like like firemen like
put your foot on a stump or whatever
the content got police officers no we're
just just like yeah yeah exactly just
take like moisturizer and put in your
hand like that's the whole
video random stuff you would do so well
yeah i i i've seen actually seen a lot
of
joke only fans and they like
creators have really leveraged like a
lot of really just like
essentially jokes and they've taken it
pretty far yeah on there for the right
price i would buy it
yeah for the right price yeah yeah
there's a lot of people who do it for
free and that's like a com that's
another reason i like only fans is
because
like you can choose your monetization
model there's a ton of girls who are
just like my only fans is free
i'll occasionally post a picture or
video that is paid so like you can
look at the preview or whatever it is
and pay for that and there's some that
just do the monthly subscription i would
do it and i'm telling you
uh only fans is such a big business um
we know somebody who is managing some of
the girls and only fans
and they're pulling in two to five
hundred thousand dollars a month yeah
and that's this and they're not like
even like the top
ones like i i love the bell delphine
interview
but like i bet she's probably doing
about two million a month from only fans
do you interview belle delphine no no
what do you mean but oh
she's unimpulsive oh okay uh but yeah
but to make two five hundred thousand
dollars a month it's ludicrous and yeah
it's insane i don't know how long it's
gonna last but i think it lasts a lot i
think it's gonna stay
uh when you look into and you realize
how like
horrendous the porn industry is and it's
just like oh this is like
long time coming like women and men
needed to
they needed a way to make their own
money if they're gonna get exploited
to that extent like they may as well
control it they need it like they need
that money in it so
it there's just like so many nasty
predatory
people out there who you know i don't
know it's just
it's a really bad scene that needed to
be disrupted so it's really good that it
did
i agree yeah so i think you're next
yes you graham you guys could do like a
joint
i'm gonna oiled up wrestle yeah
yes you know people would pay a lot of
money for that that's a
damn good idea you know what if logan
paul is going to like fight mayweather
like at least we could do
oh yeah hbo just put that on the hbo
pay-per-view like 90 yeah yeah
that'd do well man to the right price i
mean only for the right
oh yeah i am selling bath water what
yeah and the funny thing is
he's not selling a cup he's selling a
gallon
how are you gonna ship out a gallon and
you're actually giving like the water a
purpose like people can actually do
stuff with it i put that on my uh my
merch
store it's five thousand dollars like
and they put it out there just
just for jokes but if someone actually
buys it i'll do it
yeah so it's five grand until they
realize that you were serious
and you took their money after them
clicking proceed to checkout if they
checked out i would take their money but
i would actually give them what they
purchased
i would actually do it yeah yeah
speaking of which there's a guy who
offered how much like 10 grand to pie me
in the face what happened to that
i don't know he just hasn't really
followed up all right we gotta follow up
with him yeah
i said someone could pie me in the face
ten thousand dollars to charity yeah
come here pie me in the face ten grand
put it to charity that's a great idea
yeah i do have a question about dax
and in that sorry in that documentary
in that documentary it was really
interesting because i feel like i
learned a lot about you
yes instead of dax awesome that's great
to hear when
you went out in public you weren't how i
imagined you would have been because you
seemed like
nervous or a little like anxious even in
public which isn't what i would have
expected
yeah so you'll notice that in videos in
the past
um like uh the leafy content cop even
the tener mojo one
like i i'm not exactly that same way and
it's pretty much
like the character thing like i'm able
to get in a mindset
i'm able to put you know put on a little
bit of a mask and be a little bit more
exuberant because i know i'm getting
paid for it
i'm doing a job i'm completing a task
whereas in that moment
i'm like this is dax's thing and like i
am not i didn't
plan on doing i don't plan on
interviewing you so you hadn't put on
smoothies yet
yeah i was so detached like it's not me
so like i think dax has
and dax's mindset was exactly the same
when i asked him how do you do this how
do you just go up to people and be so
awkward he's like um
like it's a lot easier like knowing that
you guys are filming and it's like
oh like you would have a harder time
doing this if we weren't he's like yeah
we wouldn't really do this
and that's true that would be the same
with me yeah if i were filming i'd have
no problem with it but if if it's just
me
alone i couldn't do it yeah exactly so
that's what it comes down to
so you think how you acted in that
situation was more reflective of your
personality oh absolutely yes that's so
interesting and i was feeling i i don't
know how much of dax we showed in that
him like pep talking me but he he
like there were some really cringe
moments where i was like trying to go up
to people
and uh dax like you know kept like
really encouraging like you could do it
man
like uh it's just easy you just go up
and ask them
if they watch a youtube show about
smoothies or whatever
yeah and yeah that was so funny like
this guy's idubbbz you know who he is so
whatever he has seven million
subscribers dude that was so funny yeah
you should have shown those pep talks
yeah some of them it was a little bit
iffy because in the field we had
lab mics and they were not great there
was a lot of interference
so we had a lot of footage actually on
hollywood boulevard
but with so much stuff going on on there
like even just 10 feet away there was
already too much static and too much
noise it just kept cutting out
that's too bad all the behind the scenes
stuff patreon that oh yeah
only fansite i would love to see him
with lovely fans
i like the idea of merging like behind
the scenes and only fans content i would
don't let anyone ever you want on there
don't let anything go to waste
at all everything that uh should be i
think
you would get a better uh split on only
fans than you would
patreon probably patreon is a little
steep doesn't only
fan take like 20 it's like 20 percent
yeah what is patreon do you know i don't
know
yeah i think it's a little more i think
that's going to be 30. yeah all right oh
i feel like we're i'm going for
something
yeah yeah is there anything else you
want to talk about um
no i think we could go we could go as
long as you want okay can we get a
minute take on a couple subjects that i
just want your opinion oh yeah rapid
fire rapid fire
yeah cameo uh don't like it i'm never
going to do a cameo
but it's a great new alternative source
of income for a lot of people who have
been cancelled
um i'm on cameo
money gurus uh uh
some of them are good some of them are
bad if they want to sell you a course
probably bad that's about it logan paul
uh seems like a nice guy uh probably
would be really intimidated by my
stature if he were
to ever meet me uh and i don't blame
them
uh who else uh phase rug
uh no i didn't give you much there yeah
i don't know what i would say
mr beast mr beast
he's everywhere that's a that's a great
response anything else i feel like we
we got a great resource yeah yeah i
think we're good there's
nothing else you want to mention no i
think okay cool
all right cool oh which game am i going
to look in that one
this is okay yeah it's so bright it's so
bright here
well guys thank you so much for watching
i really appreciate it and ian thank you
so much for coming on and talking to us
for like over two hours this is one of
the longer episodes that we've done it
was worth it but
this has been so much fun next uh iced
coffee hour
podcast i'm gonna make a bold prediction
it's gonna be 56
000 made on the podcast so far so we got
to make another 20.
all right all right yeah then we'll make
20 grand let's do it twenty yeah
yeah snap your fingers you better put
some good minerals in this one oh yeah
oh yeah all right so yeah we got it we
gotta load up on sponsors on this yeah
just every other like second city
thank you our video sponsor today anyway
guys thank you so much for watching uh
i'll link to all of our information down
below in the description get your four
free stocks sign up for yatta
and uh with that said you guys until
next time
i'll pay attention to that there we go
so it's a little on the bright side but
uh
right now the lighting is works for some
reason so we're okay
i don't know why but okay it's terrible
lighting
what the lighting is kind of hectic it's
really intense usually we do these
podcasts by the way at like 7 to 8 p.m
at night
yeah um never this is the first podcast
we've done at this hour it makes you
look tan
yeah it does yeah yeah so anyway
i'm going to start the sun we're going
to stop you do it wrong though
okay
hello everyone my name is ian
welcome to the iced coffee hour
the 35th ever episode of the ice coffee
hour
my name is ian okay
ever